how do you design a thumbnail or cover
image that will catch somebody's eye and
get them to click hi I'm Matthew encina
if you don't know me I've been a
creative professional for over 15 years
working in design advertising and
creating contents in this video I'll be
sharing my process from beginning to end
for how I design this thumbnail using my
printer a few tools Photoshop and my
camera
recently I released the video on our
other channel the future as with any
YouTube video the title and thumbnail
are everything it's your first
impression of the content and it gives
your audience an idea of what the video
will be about which leads me to my goal
for designing any thumbnail it has to
convey the idea of the video in an
interesting way that will get people to
click through and watch it let's start
by talking about the concept the video
I'm making a thumbnail for is about our
unreasonably high expectations of
ourselves and what it does to our
creativity
indeed I share my personal battle with
my own high expectations which created
an unrealistic perception in my mind
about who I should be versus who I want
to be I wanted to capture this idea and
feeling somehow in the design of the
thumbnail since the video is so personal
to my experience I also wanted to add
some kind of personal touch to it
the first version of the thumbnail I
created this image to make it stand out
I took a practical analog approach using
cutout papers and crude drawings to give
it a handmade feel I wanted it to look
very different from the normally bright
and saturated thumbnails that you would
normally see on YouTube you can see the
idea here was to take the normal version
of you illustrated by the figure in the
center juxtaposed against a larger white
silhouette which represents the higher
expectation of you I released the video
using this thumbnail and it performed
okay
it had a 2.5 percent click-through rate
on YouTube which is fairly average on
our channel I wasn't satisfied with that
result so I wanted to see if I could
design a different thumbnail that would
improve that click-through rate the
second version of the thumbnail I
created this still the same concept
except using a playful illustration
style to convey it this time I removed
all of the typography and use the color
palette that I generated using Gregg
guns techniques from the color for
creative scores which I highly recommend
if you haven't taken it yet so on the
second day of the video being out I
changed the video thumbnail to this to
see if it would improve the
click-through rate to my surprise it
performed exactly the same so over the
weekend being isolated at home I got
inspired to try for a third attempt at
designing this thumbnail this time I
wanted to explore the idea of layers
literal layers on top of my face I
started by sketching this idea in my
sketchbook and I thought I'd play with
handwritten typography it printed on my
face I wanted to convey the idea that
there's the real me buried underneath
all of the expectations of
I would do this by juxtaposing a color
image behind a set of grayscale images
to show this I started by printing out a
full-color version of my face to
represent the real me as a base as well
as a few layers of black and white
variants of my portrait to place on top
of it for the black and white portraits
I wanted to play up the idea that they
didn't represent the real me to do that
I treated these portraits like they were
halftone news prints which look like
manufactured versions of me to give that
halftone look I started by converting my
photos to grayscale first and then I
adjusted the value so that the contrast
would feel a little bit more flat this
way the highest point of contrast would
be on the full-color portrait underneath
and the focus would be on my eyes then I
converted the images to bitmaps using
these settings you can insert and play
around with different values here to
change the size and spacing of the
halftone dots that will be created I
exported a few variations of these
settings and then printed them out to
play with once I had a few printed
portraits I busted out my cutting mat
box cutter a Sharpie pen and then I went
to town I first started with creating an
interpretation of my original sketch
crudely cutting out a window over my
eyes to roll back and reveal the real me
underneath then I started writing all
over my face to project all of the
expectations that were being placed on
me
when I saw the result I felt it looked a
little too messy visually and I wouldn't
be able to read this as a small
thumbnail image so I tried other
versions of this execution simplifying
it down with no typography then I
explored a version that utilize a
post-it note on top of my face to
capture those expectations then I played
with combining two different portraits
one smiling one serious to draw more
exaggeration between the two states to
create some depth between the layers I
used some dice that I had lying around
and use them as spacers in between the
pieces of paper this created some nice
shadows between the sheets by the end of
my initial explorations I realized I had
a big pile of cut-up portraits that I
intended to throw away but at that point
I got the idea to stack up all the
layers on top of each other to see what
the result might look like I'm glad I
did because that probably led to my most
interesting results I took photos of
each setup at different stages so I'd
have options to choose from for my
thumbnail of all the photos the one that
worked the best in the sixteen by nine
format for YouTube was this one a little
tip here if you're making thumbnails for
YouTube I recommend scaling your image
way down to make sure it still works
sometimes as designers we obsess over
details that don't really matter because
no one will ever really see them for
this particular thumbnail I felt that
even at the small size you could read
the image was still engaging to look at
and it might pique your curiosity if
you're scrolling through YouTube and
that should always be your goal for
designing YouTube thumbnails to make
somebody stopped from scrolling and then
click on your video and you keep them
there with your high-value content
because if you can get your audience to
click they'll never see your video now I
was ready to test this third design of
my thumbnail on the third day the video
was out I swapped the thumbnail to this
and here were the results they
click-through rate nearly doubled from
2.5% with my original design up to 4.5%
with the new design this means that the
video is now getting more views YouTube
is recommending it more in its algorithm
and my message will reach more people
and that's why it's important to design
good thumbnails or covers for your
projects so that people will click
through now that we've reached the end
let me quickly recap my process first it
was to identify my goal second I came up
with a concept and sketched it out third
I designed several executions of the
idea and the fourth step I tested each
variation to see which one would perform
best I hope you enjoyed this process
video I encourage you to try new things
explore new mediums outside of the
digital ones because analog is just so
much fun
if you want to learn more from me I'm
considering making a course to help you
learn conceptual thinking and idea
generation which I believe is the
foundation of good communication design
let me know in the comments below if
that's something you'd be interested in
in the meantime if you want to support
us check out all of our courses at the
future com every purchase there helps
fund the content we make here that's it
for me I'll see you all in the future
[Music]